Suppose we have an
object and we're
applying a constant force
in the horizontal direction.
We would now like to
introduce the concept of work.
Suppose our force
starts at a point xi,
and goes to a position
x final, and we'll
call this the i hat direction.
Then our force as a vector,
we'll write Fx i hat.
And now what we'd
like to calculate
is the product of force with
the displacement of the object.
So our displacement
vector, delta x,
is equal to delta x i hat,
where delta x is equal to x
final minus x initial.
And for our constant
force for the case
where Fx is a
constant, we would like
to define the work
done by this force
in displacing the object
from our initial position,
and we'll mark it like that.
To the final position here
is given by the product,
so we'll call work is
the product of the force
Fx times the displacement.
And so that's equal to Fx
times x final minus x initial.
And this is our definition for
work for the special case where
the force is constant.
Now, if we look at this, our
force may-- in our diagram,
we drew it in the
positive x direction.
But if our force Fx
were less than 0,
and our displacement was
in the positive direction,
positive, then you can see
that the work is negative.
So if the force is
opposing the displacement,
and that's what
would happen if Fx
was pointing in the
negative direction,
the work would be negative.
If Fx is positive and the
displacement is positive,
then the work is positive.
So we see work is a
scalar that has assigned
quantity, positive or negative.
Now, whenever we
introduce a new quantity,
we always have to be a little
bit careful about the units.
Since work is the product
of force and distance,
then our SI units for
work are the units
of force, which are newtons,
times the units of distance,
meters.
And we call this a joule.
So one joule is equal
to one newton meter.
Now graphically, we can make
an interpretation of this.
Let's draw a graph of force,
the x component of the force.
And here if we had some
origin, we'll have x.
And our object is starting at
xi and it's going to x final.
And throughout
this process, we're
assuming that the
force is constant.
So what we see in
this diagram here,
I'll just shade in this
area, that our work, which
was the product of force
times the displacement,
corresponds to the area here.
So we have a geometric
interpretation of work
as the area under the force
versus position graph.
And this is our example of
work for a constant force.